So adding attributes to instances like we did here works okay. But it doesn't
really give us what we wanted with types. We want types to be generally useful.
We don't want to have to manually add all the attributes every time we create a
new instance. We want them to be really part of the type. So the way to do this
is to add code to the class definition itself. Remember, we define the class?
And, defining a method is just like defining a procedure. The difference is it's
done inside a class. The syntax is the same, so let's try moving our display
restaurant procedure in to the restaurant class. So here's what we had before.
We just moved this inside the class, so now, its indented as a block inside the
class. I'm going to make one change to it, since now, it's inside the restaurant
class. We don't really need to have the name restaurant as part of it, so I'm
going to remove the restaurant there. And I'm going to also add a doc string,
that's just good programming practice. That, all display does is print out some
information about the restaurant. So now, let's try that, and we're going to
actually be in for surprise. Turns out, it's actually quite a pleasant surprise.
But, let's see if you can follow along what happens. So let's try that. And we
can see that there is a display attribute. That was defined as part of the
restaurant object, because this definition inside the class. And we can see what
it is, is a method. Doesn't tell us too much about the method, but it is a
method. And let's try and call it. And it takes one input will pass the
mcdowells. We're going to see that we didn't actually want to do that. So,
here's what happens, that we actually get an error. And the error we get is that
it says it takes exactly one argument, but there were two given. Hm, I don't see
two arguments, I only see one. Well, this is a shortcut that we get with
methods. And, the shortcut we get is the first argument is actually this one,
it's the one before the name of the method. So here's what's going on here. If
we have an object followed by a dot, followed by an attribute, which is the
method, and we pass in parameters. What that really means is that we're calling
this method with the first parameter already bound to this object. So there's a
little bit of magic, which is that the parameter's already bound to the object,
but otherwise, it's just like a normal procedure call. So let's look more
closely at what the value of the mcdowells.display attribute is. It's a bound
method, and that means it's already got its first input bound, and it's bound to
the object that was created so this is the restaurant object. If we look at
McDowell's, that's exactly the object that it's bound to. These values here
don't really mean anything other than they allow us to uniquely identify
objects. So we can see that it's bound to the same object as McDowell's. And
now, if we call it, we only need to pass in no parameters, since the first
parameters is the one that's already bound. And now, we still get an error, we
get an attribute error, because our object has no name attribute. We need to
give it one. And now, when we call the display method, we add an attribute to
this object. We didn't change the object. So, display is still bound to the same
object we created, which now has a name attribute. And now display, prints out
McDowell's Mansion of Meatiness.